for the mammals there are two special
rooms that are under controlled
environmental conditions this is called
the bone room where all the large
skeletal skulls of large body species
are housed
so the whales the elephants that bears
various pinnipeds marine mammals
hippopotamus rhinoceros all that kind of
material is in ear to floor straight
down below us is what we call the fur
room so the furs that have been tanned
for the most part that belonged to most
of these skulls in here our house
downstairs wombats monkeys Komodo dragon
beavers capybara the world's largest
rodent tastes like chicken
marking Fox coyote over here mountain
lions
tiger Snow Leopard Lynx this is a
Wolverine if you haven't that's a sea
otter the rationale behind both the bone
room and the furrow ms those cases are
$1,000 a piece so you don't use one to
store an elephant skull or a caribou hi
so all of the big specimens with the
tanned hides like this red kangaroo are
stored down here and like for the bone
room there it's kept at a cooler
constant temperature a lot of these
specimens were preserved in the same way
that that was Mouse skins were that I
showed you up above so their skin is
stripped off they're stuffed with cotton
wires have been put in the feet in the
tail and they've been pinned out to you
know to dry most of the kind of what we
call mesial carnivores the intermediate
sized animals and everything above the
skins are stripped off and then they're
ten you know professional furriers we
don't get
very many of these kinds of specimens
anymore and they're not used as much as
they used to be used but they're used
for very interesting and novel ways
today that ways that we're not even
thought about you know when they were
collected the most common uses of
material like this now is for the look
at environmental contaminants so we have
material collected before the release of
various environmental contaminants heavy
metals or even pesticides in the
environment you can take hairs or skin
samples from these specimens that were
collected before that compared to
specimens today and look at a heavy
metal load it's a kind of natural
background and so that's what I said
before is that one of the one of the
goals of maintaining a collection like
this is to maintain as much as you can
not just for the purpose that it can be
used today but trying to anticipate what
purposes that might be used as
techniques become available under the
future
this is is a big call to babba rusev
from Indonesia where the male's their
upper Tufts are elevated and go over the
top of the skull it's used to entice
young ladies young lady